- We realized it was covered
in hundreds of praying mantis babies .
I can't wait.
(laughing)
All right people.
Christmas is one week away and
the only thing that's better
than the magic of the holidays
and hanging out with everyone
and having a good Christmas time
with your family and friends
is when you send in your
Christmas fails to me
and then I get to read them all out
for the entire world to get to laugh
at a tiny bit of your expense
because it's funny.
And you've shared with
the class so it's okay.
So this is what we like to
call "Hilarious Holiday Fails".
Okay. So Susanna Vitale, maybe.
I don't know. It looks
like a fancy last name.
Wrote, she is going to kill me
but the tree fell on my
mother-in-law one year.
Okay. Wait. So this is apparently
what it's supposed to be.
Oh snap.
(laughing)
Is she okay?
Oh my gosh. You can see
her hands under the tree.
We told her this should
be her Christmas card.
She has never lived this
down nor will she ever.
Oh my gosh. That had to kind of hurt.
Sorry, mom.
Okay. So the next one is Shawntay Schmidt.
She wrote, when my son was three,
my parents gave us their
five foot dancing Santa.
My dad pulls Santa out of
the box and he has no head.
Thinking quickly he pushes
on Santa's shoulders
and Santa springs up.
Out rolls his head across
our living room floor.
My son ran upstairs and hid in his room.
It took a very long time
for him to look at Santa
the same way again.
That's kind of awesome. Oh my God.
He had no head and then it popped out.
Oh and the kid. The kid was terri-
That's traumatizing
From David.
For my kids, this was a
Christmas nightmare. Okay.
(laughing)
Oh my God. I love that everybody has that-
Oh, those are cute boots.
Cool cowboy boots on that little one.
Come on now.
Okay. So from Taylor, last
year versus this year.
Okay. Last year versus-
(laughing)
Okay. I gotta be honest with you.
I am first of all, impressed
that you have the same Santa
every year.
I've never done that. Like that's amazing.
And secondly, I only have one year
that my kids freaked out.
They didn't do both it both years.
You're lucky Taylor.
So from Kaitlin.
I think Santa was about
to have a meltdown too.
Here we go. I can't wait.
(laughing)
Oh my God. I love these pictures.
Look at this one. She's like Joan of Arc.
She's like revolt and she's rebellious.
It's like amazing and he's
just sad. That's awesome.
- [Andy] And that one
baby is still asleep.
- The baby's still asleep.
She fine. Oh my God.
We traumatize our children, don't we?
We're like just take the picture. Smile.
Oh my gosh. I love it.
Ryan C wrote, we went out as
a family to cut down a tree.
Two days later, our cat
started attacking the tree.
We realized it was covered
in hundreds of praying mantis babies
and they were all over the tree and walls.
Oh gross.
Have you ever seen a
praying mantis up close?
I mean, they are really
cool looking alien things.
I have a couple that live in my backyard
that we always just see
and they look like aliens.
With the big eyes.
They look so cool
and they're so bizarre
looking and like cool looking.
That would scare me if
there were like a ton of,
yeah mm.
- [Andy] How are you with insects?
- I'm okay with insects generally.
Um like spiders, like all that stuff
that doesn't really bother me.
There's one thing that I
don't do and that's roaches.
Yeah. I can take any little bug but
sorry.
And I even, I'm the kind
that like scoop up the bug
and take the bug outside, you know,
but if it's a roach, you're dying
because you've outlived
everything else so far.
You won't outlive me.
This one is from Katherine
Queen. That's amazing.
One year, the Turkey for
Christmas was definitely
not going to get done in time for dinner
with the whole family.
So we all had our Christmas fixings'
with Burger King burgers.
It did not become a tradition, thank God.
I cook Turkey the day before now.
Well done. You know what,
way to be innovative.
Michael writes, at Thanksgiving this year,
I wanted to propose to my
girlfriend in front of her family
at dinner.
Ooh bold.
Her favorite thing about
Thanksgiving was pecan pie
with a Graham cracker crust
so I secretly put the engagement ring
inside the top of the pie.
Before, this is a bad idea,
before we were about to say
what we were thankful for
we all hear a loud crash in the kitchen
and we go in to see my
sister's dog had pulled the pie
off the counter and had
eaten it all in seconds.
Surprise ruined.
It took two days for us
to give that ring back.
That's a great story.
I wonder if he told her that day
or just let the dog poop
it out and then told her.
And then that's the ring you're getting?
You're getting a poop ring?
I don't know if that's a good omen.
Merry Christmas. I hope you
enjoy the holiday feels.
And I hope that you feel if
something does fail this year,
look you're in good company.
It happens to the best of us.